In this course, Jim will help you improve
your Python skills by teaching you how to
build a minesweeper game. Jim has created
many popular courses on our channel,
and is an excellent teacher. So he just started to
learn Python and you will want to develop a cool
project after learning the basics. Well, this
series of videos is exactly for you, because in
this series of videos, we are going to develop
a game with Python. Now if you know the basics,
and you took some basic course, no matter what
channel or what course it is, then this is the
series that you are looking for, because it will
give you the basics of how to start structuring a
Python project. Now in this series, we will
develop a game that is called Minesweeper,
which is known as a single player game that is
very fun to play, and also challenging. Let's see
what game you will learn to develop in that
series. Alright, so that's going to be the
game that we will be developing throughout the
series. Now we can see that we have some amount
of sales that we can go click and open them. Now
the main goal in Minesweeper is to not click on a
sale that has a mind behind the sale. So what that
means it means that if I was to go and open it,
then you can see I receive a number back. Now this
means that in the surrounding sales of that sale,
there is one mind that I should not click on. So
I'm going to guess and say that you don't have in
mind here. And you also don't have in mind there.
And you can see that I'm quite right. So I'm going
to click with my right click of the mouse to mark
it as a mind because if I was to click that with
my left mouse click, then y will lose the game,
right. So what I'm going to do now is to try to
get the rest of the locations that are mindless
locations, right, so I'm going to click there.
And you can see that I received some numbers, you
can see that, for example, around the sale, I have
zero mine, so it is safe to click here, here and
as well as there. And now let's try to left click
on that location. And you can see that it says you
clicked on a mind and I lost a game. And the main
goal is really to get all the locations that are
not having a mind and then you will win the game.
So that's going to be a lot of thinking that we
have to do in order to develop that game. And it's
going to be cool dealing with all the challenges
that this game brings with it. So before we get
started, I'd appreciate if you can click on a like
button on that video, it will help to spread the
video to the entire YouTube. And also if you know
people that are just starting to learn Python,
and they want to develop a cool project,
then welcome them to watch my series as well,
it could be very helpful for those videos that
are just in the level of between getting started
and to being an expert. So with that being said,
let's get started. Now before we get into writing
this project, I will expect to you to have Python
installed on your computer. And as well as a an
IDE that is ready to go with and it recognizes
the Python interpreter on your computer,
I'm going to use Python 3.8. But as long as you
have a version that is above that version, then
you should be fine writing this project. Now we
are not going to use too much external libraries,
or too much code that is dependent on the
version of the Python. So that's okay,
if you even use python three point 10 Or python
three point 11 That will upcoming in the future
probably. All right. So let's go ahead and get
started. Now for writing a board game a 2d game,
then we can use a lot of libraries that are
available in Python. In this one, we are going
to use TK inter which is very nice and a great
library to practice because it comes with a lot of
useful classes that we are going to instantiate
to create our window. So we're going to start by
importing this in the following way. So I will
say from tkinter, import everything. And that
will be a great starter for us. So the next line
that I'm going to write here is to instantiate a
window instance. And we probably want to do that
because our project is going to be in a window,
and I'm going to name my variable root and this
one is going to be equal to an instantiation of
that key role the T K. And that's just the most
basic elements that you can create. This is just
a regular window. Now when we will run this then
nothing is going to happen because we need to tell
to that TK that it should run until we close it
with the X button on the top right. So that will
be by saying route dot main loop like that, right.
So we need to call that method and all the code is
going to be between those two lines. So if we were
to run that, and you can see that we have the most
basic window that is possible. Now just a quick
sidenote, the reason that I used the root variable
is just a convention in TK inter project. So it
will be easier for you to look up for problems in
Stack Overflow. For example, if you follow those
conventions or So let's go ahead and see some of
the attributes that we can change here to make
our window nicer. So the first one is going to
be obviously to change the size of the window. And
we can do that by calling the geometry function,
I mean method of this route. And this accepts a
string that is looking like the following weight,
X, the height. And here, obviously, you can
put any numbers you would like to now pay
attention what will happen if I was to replace
those with actual numbers like the following,
then you will see the difference immediately.
And if I was to run that, then you can see how it
changes. Now we can also pay attention that it
uses this string as the title of our window,
we can change that by calling a method that is
called Title and give it any title that we like
to. So we can go with a minesweeper game, and re
execute our program. And you can see the changes.
Now, I did not talk about this. But by default,
all the windows are resizeable. And that might be
something annoying when you create a lot of
elements inside this window like buttons or
frames. So that's why we probably look to avoid
resizing this window, because it will just give
us an easier life when we go ahead and put some
more elements in that window. So the way that
this is achievable, is by calling the resizeable
method like that, and basically specify that
we are not allowed to resize the width and the
height of this window. And that is achievable by
basically passing in false twice, one for
the weight, and the other one for the height.
Now, if I was to again, rerun our program, then
you can see the effect of that you can see that
this maximize here is disabled. And that's just
something that's going to make us an easier life
in the future when we develop this game. Now after
we reach that stage, then we might also be curious
about how to change the background color of
our window. Now, you could go ahead and use
hexadecimal values if you know how to use them.
But basically, it gives them supports a lot of
keywords for specifying the colors. Now we don't
want to too much deal with styling, we pretty much
want to focus on the logic in the algorithm of
how to write such a game. So for that purpose,
I'm going to keep it simple. But still, we want to
obviously have a nice visualized window in here.
So I'm going to go to that fifth line. And I'm
going to say router dot Configure. And we're
going to need to configure the background color
for our window. So we need to go ahead and call
this method and we need to pass in BG equals to
whatever color we like to. Now in the description,
you can find a list of colors that are available
by using key word colors. So in the description,
there is a link with a large list of colors that
are available, I'm just going to use black for
this window. And that will be added so you can see
the immediate effect of changing the background
color. Alright, so now that we understood this,
then let's go ahead and see how we can create
some elements inside our window. Now we are going
to start with the most basic elements that you can
create in a window, which is called a frame. Now
frame is just like a container that could contain
more elements that we will create in the future.
Now we want to use those frames, because obviously
we want to divide our window into some sections.
So it will be easier to understand where we want
to locate each of our buttons or texts in
the future. For example, we could dedicate
that area of our window for a title, right, so
we will have the title over here. And we could
decide that we'd like to have a left sidebar.
So we could dedicate the left area of our window
into being the sidebar to display the score, for
example, something like that. And we could have
another frame right here. So we call display the
game here. So it is just a great idea to divide
the window into multiple frames, it's going to
be just helpful to visualize different elements
later on. So what I'm going to do now is
writing here a comment that will say override
the settings of the window. And right before
the root.me loop, I'm also going to comment out
run the window and then here is the exact location
that we will start creating some frames. So let's
go ahead and get started. So we said that we'd
like to have a frame that is located on the top.
So I will name this variable top frame and that
will be equal to a class that is named frame.
And once we will instantiate from this frame
class, then it will be responsible to instantiate
a frame which we will decide later on where we'd
like to Located on our Windows. Now the first
argument that this frame must receive is what is
the element that we'd like to locate the frame in.
So it is going to be located in the window. So we
will pass in root. And then I'm going to separate
those into multiple lines. So it will be easier
to read. And as you can see, the parentheses are
open here, close in here. Now let's go ahead and
give it more attributes. So first things first,
we'd like to give a different background. So
we can really differentiate between the frame
and the window because it is going to be hard to
understand where the frame is located, if we keep
the same color, so just for debugging reasons,
I'm keeping this red change later to black.
And we'll comment that here. And then down here,
I will decide the weight and the height. So I will
say that the weight should be equal to the exact
same width size we gave to the window because we'd
like to cover the entire window. So this should be
the entire weight, like the window, and the height
should be probably one ad like that. So it is just
seven on the 20 divided to foreign, that makes
totally sense. And now that we got this, then we
need to decide where we'd like to start this frame
from. So in order to do this, then I'm going to
go ahead and say top underscore frame dot place.
Now this place will receive two arguments that are
mandatory. And before I go ahead and pass those,
let me show you how the placement works in
the window here. So when we use the placement,
then it needs to receive the pixels value. Now we
know that we have a frame that we'd like to start
exactly from here. And we know that it should
probably cover this area, right. But how we are
going to tell it to start it from here. Well in
place, we need to specify the axis x and axis Y,
meaning that if we want to start from the top
left, then we need to give it the values of
0.0. Because that is where everything starts in
terms of pixels. Now, the entire area here is 1400
for the because that is the axis x and axis, y
is 720 pixels. So the entire height here is 720.
Now if for example, we would want to have
a button just for example, I'm not going
to do that that time. But let's say that we'd
like to have a button that we wanted to start
here. So we wanted to place it in the middle of
our page, right, so we need to take that value
and divide it with two, so the axis x is 720. And
we know that we would like to have it in the top
position as much as possible. So this should
be the value of axis y which will be zero.
So that's how the place method works, we need to
specify the pixel value four axis x and axis y.
And let me clean everything that I draw here and
go back to Python and give here the values of x
equals to zero and y equals to zero. And now
check out how this frame will be visualized.
If I stop and rerun, then you can see that this
is the expected result just like we wanted,
it started from here and took the entire area of
weight, and it took 180 pixels from the height. So
that's exactly what we want it now just for really
making sure that you understood this, I am going
to change this to x to 20. And you will guess
what will happen. So if we were to read on that,
then obviously it will start from a little bit
left positional you can see where it is located
right it starts just in here. And if we were to
jump to y by 20 and stop and rerun this, then
you can see the results. So this is how the place
method works. Obviously, I'm going to change those
back to zero and continue from here. Alright, so
now that we understood that, then let's go ahead
and try to create one more frame. Now this time
I want to make a frame that we will use as a left
sidebar, where we will display maybe the score
or something else that is useful. So I'm going
to go ahead and create a left frame variable
and that's going to be equal to the frame. So
we will instantiate one more from that class. And
we want this frame in the crude and then we will
say something like BG equals to another color.
I will just copy that line and paste it In a and
let's use something like blue so we can separate
between different frames, and the weight will be
360, I'm intentionally using the value that
is just a quarter of that value. So it will
be easier for me to understand how much percentage
of the entire weight I covered with my frames. Now
that I specify the width, I'm going to specify the
height. So I'm going to say that this should cover
the entire height of our window. Now pay attention
that we already covered 100 ad pixels for the
top frame. So we cannot just say 700 ad, I mean,
seven and 20. Like that, we need to go ahead and
remember our height size of the entire window
and subtract this number by that number,
right. So we should be passing year 500.
For the now, don't worry if you think that
we hardcode too much values, I am going to make
sure that we don't really have any hard coded
values later on, when we will be restructuring
this project in the future. So now we are focusing
on understanding how TK inter works. So now that
we understood that, then let's go ahead and say
that left frame should be placed in x equals to
zero, but the y should be equal to 180, right,
because we want to start it right after where
the top frame is located. And if I was to run our
program, then you can see that we have the perfect
result. Just to really understand that again, if
we were to take that Y axis and jump that by 20,
then you can see that it starts right from here,
because it jumped 20 pixels in the y axis. So
that's why I want to make sure that we keep
the value of 100 ad. Alright, so now that we have
reached that stage, you can notice probably that
we are going to have too much hard coded numbers
in terms of using the weight and the height and
the pixels, etc. So that's a great time having a
separated file for all of our constants, and have
at least some variables stored in somewhere. Now,
I'm not going to make that in our main.py file,
because that might be too much information that
needs to be stored in one file, besides I'm going
to grab in a new Python file, and I'm going to
call that settings. So inside here, I can use
some constants that will be helpful. And to really
show you those windows side by side, let me use
the right click and split vertically option. So
we can start thinking about some good candidates
for variables that we'd like to store here.
For example, we can start with the width size
of our window, we can say that width is equal to
1440, we can say that the height is equal to 720.
And we can immediately go back to our main.py
file and say something like import settings.
And then we could go here and use a formatted
string. And we could just convert those
into that string, right, we can say here,
settings, dot width. And we can go with settings
dot height, like that. And that's just a great
change in our project. Now, if I was to run our
main file, then you can see that nothing is
really changed. And we are in good position to
continue doing those manipulations to store more
variables. Now, if you remember, I said in the
tutorial that I used intentionally those numbers,
so we could have an accurate percentage of the
weight size. For example, there was a great
reason that I use the 100 ad value in the top
frames height, because one of the ad times for is
similar to 20. So I can say that I like to consume
25% of the entire height of our window. And those
are things that are important because we will not
have too much hard coded values. So what we can do
now is having a file for some functions that could
be helpful to calculate those stuff. For example,
we could have a function that will calculate
how much is 20% of the entire height of
our window, right? So we can go ahead and
use another Python file for that. We can call it
utilities or utils. And we could have a function
that will calculate the percentage amount of our
height. At first we could go ahead and use import
settings so we We'll import the settings of our
project. And we could go ahead and use a function.
So let's call this function height underscore
PRC T, just a shortened version of percentage,
right, so we could go ahead and receive
here, the percentage amount as a parameter,
we make this a bit smaller. And then I can just
go ahead and inside that, I can return the value
relying on the received argument in here. So I can
go ahead and use return. And I can say, settings
dot height, divided by 100. And I can cover this
thing with parentheses. And I can multiply that
with the percentage amount. So now I
want to validate that I have done a
great job of writing this function, right, I
don't immediately want to call my functions,
and just try to use them because I might have a
bug when I write a function. And that's also a
great advantage locating different functions in
different files, because it will give you a huge
advantage of debugging your stuff. So for example,
I could temporarily only execute the utils.py
file and just test my function, I could go ahead
and try to call it and passing il 25. and validate
that I will really receive 100 ad back. So I
can go ahead and use print, and execute utils.
So I'm not executing my original project. And
now if you go ahead and you see the value here,
you can see that I really receive one ad. And
that's good. That means that we have done a great
job of writing this function. And now I can
really start using it in our original project
meaning in the main.py file, so I can go ahead and
import all the utils file as well I can say import
utils. And I can go ahead and call
the height percentage function,
I can use utils dot height, PRT CT and pass in
25. And again, this will have no effect. This
means that we have done a great job only now we
are more dynamic and we do not hard code values.
We are going to repeat ourselves with the
weight very quickly. And then we will move
on to the next topic, right, so I'm going to go
here, and I'm going to use this height, I mean
weight, PR city, we will receive again percentage,
and we will say return open a parenthesis just so
we can have a cleaner look in this formula. And
we can say settings dot width divided into 100
multiplied by the present age. So now I can go
ahead and do pretty much the same in the different
hard coded values here. So let's take a look.
So in the top frame, we use the entire window.
So it makes sense to change this just to the value
of settings dot width, right because it is already
1440. Let's go to our left frame. So in the left
frame, we see that we use 25% of the entire width.
So we can go ahead and use utils dot height PR
CT, excuse me, with brct I will change that. And
then I will pass in 25. And you can also see that
in the height, we use 75% of our entire height.
So that means that I can just use here utils dot
height Poct and passing year 75. And I can do the
same when I want to locate my left frame. And you
can notice how the y axis value here is again 25%
of the entire height. So I can say utils
dot height brct and pass in here 25%.
Now let's see if we have done a great job, you
can see that the result is again perfect. Alright,
so now that we got this, then let me change those
to the original values and continue from here to
creating our last frame here. So we said that we
like to have also one more frame that is going
to be in the center of our page. So that we will
have a frame that will be dedicated for our game,
right. So I will quickly go ahead and create a
center frame that will be again equal to a frame
and this should be inside route the background
should be maybe green so we can separate it.
I will need to change all of those to Black just
in a few minutes. And then I like to say weight
is equal to utils dot weight PR city and this time
I'd like to use 75% of our entire width and the
height is going to be again utils dot height
ferocity and this will be 75 percent as well,
now the place method will receive the following
arguments. So the x value should be utils dot
with PRC at 25%. Because we
want to start it from here,
and the height, meaning the y axis should be
the same, right, so I'm going to duplicate that,
and Y and change this to height periodicity. Like
that, because we want this one to start from here,
right, so it's going to take 360 pixels
from the left, and 180 pixels from the
top. So now, if we were to test our code, then
you're going to see that we have just the expected
result. So now it's a great time to change our
frames to black. Because we have done a great job,
we can go ahead and change those to black. Now
what you're going to see is just a window that
is looking like a pure black window. But in the
background, in the real Python code, we have two
frames that are divided, just like we wanted. So
now that I have changed the entire background to
black thing, we are just going to see the same.
But in the background in the original code, we
really have two frames, I mean three frames, okay,
so until this point, we know that we have a frame
here. And we also have a frame that is here.
Now, we said that around here we are going to
write some information about the game. And
here we will have the Minesweeper title
like that, right. But what we want to do
here in the center is actually developing the
board, right, the each cell that a player is
going to click on should be here. And here,
we should locate all of our cells. Now creating
hard coded 36 cells or 49 cells, basically just
a huge amount of sales is going to be hard.
So here's the exact location that we want to
make our stuff a little bit more dynamic, we
want to be able to go ahead and do a for loop
that will go ahead and create those kinds of cells
dynamically. Now, we also want to do behavior for
each sell the kind of a button behavior so called
because we want the ability to click on something.
And then next thing is something will happen
in the game right, we will see some information
about that sale. So that is the exact time for
creating a class that we can name it cell because
we know that for each cell, we also like to give
some attributes like if the cell is mine or not.
Or if this is a cell that is already opened or
it is closed. So that's exactly the time that
it is a great idea thinking about creating a class
that we could name Sal. And we could create some
instances of that later on. Now, just as a quick
example, I'm going to delete that after I'm going
to show you the basic example. But here's how you
can create a button on a window using the TK Inter
Library, right, so let's use a random variable
like button one. And that will be equal to
button like that. Now this button is
going to receive several arguments.
Let's say that we want this inside our center
frame. And we want to give the background color of
blue. And let's give it a text. Sorry for
missing the comma here. Let's give it a text
like first button. And then what I'm going to
do now is going to say button one dot place,
we will place it in the first pixel in x axis and
y axis in the center frame. So it should be in the
very top left position have that center frame,
right. So if we were to go ahead and run this,
then you can see that I have a button right there
and it is clickable. Now we know that we want to
abstract it with our custom class because we need
to give that cell so called some attributes as I
described earlier. So that's why I want to create
a cell class. And then we will also see how the
button class is going to be involved within
that cell class we will start developing but
let's actually go ahead and start working on this
right. So I just wanted to show you how to create
a button before we go ahead and write some more
code. So I will go here and create a cell Python
file right and I will zoom in a bit so everyone
can see and I will use class. So now temporarily,
I don't want to inherit from the button class
right because it is not quite correct to say that
a cell is a kind of button we know that we use
inheritance to describe kinds of things like dog
is a kind of animal. So dog class should inherit
from a class that is an animal class. But that is
not exactly the case you will. So I'm not doing
that. And now that I created this class, let's go
ahead and write the constructor of our class. Now
as we know constructor is a metal that is going
to be called immediately once a class is being
instantiated. Now I will receive temporarily here,
one parameter, which I'm also going to provide
it a default value of false. And you can see that
it is called is mine, right, and I'm going to say
self.is underscore mine is equal to is underscore
mine, like the following. Alright, so now that we
have this, let's see how we are going to use it
in our code. So I will go to my main.py file. And
we'll scroll just above this comment here, run the
window. And I will need to import the class for
sure. So let's go ahead and use from cell which is
the file, import the sale class like that, right,
and I'm just going to place it in that line.
So we will have a cleaner look. And now I'm going
to go here, and I'm just going to say c one is
equal to sell. And then I'm just going to leave
it as it is because it has a default value of
false. And now that I have this, then I can just
go ahead and run it. And you can see that the
class the instantiation is probably a good because
we don't receive any arrows. Now obviously, we
don't see any button here because we just created
a custom class without relating it to the button
class that comes from this TK inter library.
So now this is exactly what we are going to do.
Right, we are going to go to our cell file,
and we are going to create a button instance
that is going to be belong to each cell
object. So what that means, it means that this
self is going to receive one more attribute
that we could name it sell button object,
something like that. And then we are going
to assign it a button object. And that's how
the relationship between the sale objects and
the button object is going to be accomplished.
So first things first, I'm going to close the
game temporarily. And I'm going to go here and say
from T A inter import. You know what, let's
import just the button class. Let's not use
a wildcard import here. And now I'm going to go
ahead and say that this should be equal to none
at first. And then what we're going to do
now is going to create an instance method
that will create this button for
us and I will assign it to self dot
sale button object. Let's take a look how we
are going to do that. So I'm going to say Create
button object. And we will receive self only
for now. And we are going to say here button
is equal to a button like that. And we are just
instantiating an instance of that button class.
Now currently, we do not receive any additional
parameters other than the self, which is mandatory
in instance methods. So we need to be receiving
at least one parameter that is quite important,
which we can name it location, because we know
that for each element that we'd like to create
in our window, we should be passing in a piece of
information that will make TK into to understand
where it should locate that element. So if we
receive a parameter that is called location,
then I can just pass in the location directly.
And then whenever I call this method,
I will refer to the actual sensor frame
which will be from the main.py. That's why
I'm receiving here the location parameter, right.
And just for a temporarily example, let's give it
also a random text like text like that just as a
beginner. And then I'm going to say that self dot
sale btn object is going to be equal to the
object of the button that I have just created.
And that is going to be helpful because that
will help me to later on customize this button
once I assign these attributes into a button
object, and you're going to see just in a minute
how that is going to be extremely helpful. So
let's go ahead and split now vertically so we can
understand what we have done here. So on the left
side, we have the cell file and on the left side,
I'm going to work on my main.py file. So
what I'm going to do now here is going to
go ahead and say c one dot Create button object
because I can allow myself to call that button
and then I have the ability to pass in the
location because center frame is a variable
that is accessible from the main.py file, right
so I can directly say center frame as a parameter.
And then I can keep working with my button object
thanks to the attribute With a sine wave that
I have done here, right, so I can go down
and I can say c one, dot cell btn object,
dot place like that. And I can say that I would
like to place it in x equals to zero and y equals
to zero, just like we have done in the beginning
of this episode. And now that I have done this,
then it is a great time testing our code. So I'm
going to run this application and you're gonna
see that we are having that button. So that's a
very fine start developing this application and
spreading the code in different files. So it will
be more maintainable and more readable. Alright,
so now that we have done this, then we need
to understand that we are going to have some
problems in the future, if we will keep using
that placement or in order to place our elements.
Now in order to show you the problem that I'm
talking about, I'm going to create here one more
instance of the same class that we came up with.
So I'm going to say that c two is equal to a cell,
like the following. And then I'm going
to say c two dot Create button object,
and it's going to be center frame again. And
then I want the cell just near the first sale,
right. So I shouldn't be saying something
like see to that sale button object dot place.
And then we should know dynamically how much
pixels we should jump, right in order to place
it exactly in the location that we want. But
that's going to be a lot of headache, and a lot
of trouble, always knowing the exact location
that we want to pass. Because, for example,
let's say that I will pass in x equals to
20 and y equals to zero and run our game.
Now, you can see here that the right button looks
like it is before the left button, because we can
almost not see the text on the left button here.
So we can try to increase this amount of X to 40,
something like that, and re execute our game. And
you can see that now it is much better. But when
we want to deal around creating multiple elements
dynamically, then maybe using the placement or
isn't the best option here. So we need to consider
changing our placement method when we use TK inter
when it comes to 10s of elements that we want
to create dynamically. And we can do this by
changing our method from place to grid. Now
what grid does, it takes the parent element,
which is quite right there, and it turns
the parent element into columns and rows.
Now the beauty is it counts from zero the columns
and rows. So for example, if we want to place a
button right there, then we can say that we'd
like to greet that, and then give it some values
that will be considered as the column number
and the roll number. Let's see this in action,
right. So it might be a little bit confusing to
understand in the theory. But now that we will
go ahead and code this, it will be easier to
understand. So I'm going to delete everything
from here and go back to pi charm. And actually
go ahead and change the placement method from
grid on both of those buttons here. So I'm
going to go to my C one and I'm going to say
grid, and then I'm going to pass in here column
equals to zero and row equals to zero like that.
Now I'm going to grab those arguments and pass in
the same changing this method to greet as well.
And then you're going to see the difference when I
will be saying here rho equals to one. And now if
we were to go ahead and run our program, then you
can see that we have a difference. This text here
is used to be at column zero, row zero, but this
one used to be placed at column zero row one and
that is the reason you see the second button under
the first button. And if I was to change this
to zero, and make that one, meaning column
equals to one, then you're gonna see those
buttons one near each other, which is perfect. And
it will be helpful when we want to create tons of
buttons in order to start preparing for the
Minesweeper game. Alright, so now that we
understood how the grid method works, then we are
going to start creating those cells like we want
in our minds, we put game now that's something
that we can achieve with a nested for loop. So
let me show you how it's going to look like so
it will be easier to maintain in the future. And
let's delete this first. So I'm going to start my
first for loop and I'm going to say for x in range
of five for example. Now range is just a function
that is responsible to generate all the integers
in the given the range of numbers. If I was only
passing your five, then it will generate 0123
and four like that. Right. So I'm going to go
inside here and then I I'm going to say for y
in range of five. So I'm basically achieving here
the behavior of creating 25 buttons because I have
a loop that iterates, five times inside and a loop
that iterates as well, five times. So now I can go
inside of that. And I can say that c is equal
to sell. So I'm instantiating an object of it.
And then I can go ahead and say, create btn
object. And as the location, I will pass in
central frame for sure. So now that we have
created the button object, then I can access it
with the property that we have created previously,
which was cell btn object and I can use the grid
option. And then I can pass in column equals to
y. And I can say row is equal to Wickes. Like
that. And now let's see the result of that. So I'm
going to run that. And you can see how beautiful
it looks like. Right, so we are already starting
to see something similar to a minesweeper game.
And that's perfect. Now what we can do, instead
of hard coding in the five on those four loops,
we can actually allow ourselves to go to the
settings file, and write here a new setting
that can look like grid size. And then we can
decide that it is equal to any number we like to
I will say six, just because this was the
number that I showed in the beginning of
this entire series as an example game. And
then I'm going to go here and say, settings,
dot grid size. Now, remember, I import the
entire settings file right there, right,
so I can access the grid size variable.
And I can also say here, the same thing.
And then I can just run our program again, and
you can see how it looks like. So we have a six
columns and rows like that. And that's just
a great starter. Now, before we go ahead,
sorry about the confusion here, I think it will
be better if we will say column equals to x
and row equals to y. Because if we were to, for
example, change this to three and not the settings
dot grid size, then it's going to be more accurate
to say that we have three rows, right, one, two,
and three. So that's why I'm going to stick for
those column equals to x and row equals to y,
like the following. And then now
I can just convert this back to
Settings dot grid size, and continue from here.
Alright, so now that we totally understood this,
then we probably want to also understand how we
can assign events to our buttons. Now an event is
basically a list of actions that you want to
take once you click on a button. Now we said
in the beginning of this entire series that
we like to differentiate between the action
that we are taking when we left click on a button
or when we right click on a button, right because
those are two different actions in a minesweeper
game. So that is going to be very cool designing
this thing in the Minesweeper game, giving the
events for our buttons is actually very fun part
of our game. So let's see how we can do that. So
I'm going to go to my cell.py file. And here's the
exact location that we can start assigning some
events to the buttons that we create. Because
that's exactly the location that we create our
button object, we can also go ahead and assign
it an event. Now let's go ahead and write this.
So when we want to assign an event to a button,
then we want to work with a specific method that
is called bind. So with bind, we can actually go
ahead and say that we like to print something
when we left click on a button. And let's see
how we are going to do that. So we're going to
need to pass in two arguments, the first argument
being the key that is clicked on the button. And
as well as what is the function that you want to
be executing once you click on whatever button you
click at. So first things first, we want to say
that we want to do something when we left click on
a button. And the convention with the TK enter for
passing in the left click is going to be something
like the following. So I'm going to use the less
than sign. And I'm going to say button capitalized
dash one greater than sign. So button dash one is
just a convention of saying left click button dash
three is going to be right click and we're gonna
see this just in a second. And then we also like
to say that we'd like to execute some function,
right? That's going to be the second argument
of the bind method. So let's start with the most
minimalistic function that we can come up with. So
I'm going to create a metal inside my soul class,
which I'm going to be calling left click Actions
like that and that's going to also receive silver
for sure it's an instance man Third,
and then it's only going to say,
I am left clicked, just as a basic example,
I'm going to leave it as it is. And now that
we have done this, then I can easily pass in the
reference for that method. So it's not going to
be like left click Actions. And I'm going to call
this method like that, besides, I'm just going to
give it the reference, like the following. So pay
attention that you are not calling this method,
you are only passing the reference of
that method. So now that we got this,
then let's check it out and see if that is going
to work for us. So I'm going to go here and make
this a little bit bigger. And I'm going to
try to click on one of those cells here.
And you can see that we have an error. Now you
can see that it says here, a left click Actions
takes one positional argument, but two were
given. Now that might be a familiar arrow that you
may be so in my op series, but basically,
this means that this self click Actions
tries to pass in two arguments, when it
tries to call the left click Actions method.
Now, that means that this method needs to be
receiving one more additional parameter in order
to make this event assignment successfully. And
that comes from just as a convention of Kindle,
it needs to be receiving one more parameter,
when you assign something to an event might be
a little bit confusing, but that's the way that
events are working in TK into. So by convention,
I am only going to receive in an initial parameter
that I'm going to call it event. Now this will
be enough because tkinter tries to pass into
arguments. So passing year, another parameter here
shouldn't be perfect. So I'm going to re execute
the program. And then I'm going to try to click on
some buttons. And you can see that we have a great
result here. For each button that I'm clicking,
I am receiving this text of I am left clicked and
that is perfect. Now I'd also like to add in here,
one more line, which will be responsible to print
in the info that comes to that event parameter.
And you're gonna see that it is actually filled
in with some information that TK into passes in,
in the background. So now let's again run
our game. And if I was to click on something,
then you can see that I received some info
about what was the event that is all killed.
So you can see that I have a button press event
state equals to mod one, just basically some
metadata about the event that has been occurred in
that moment. And you can also see that I received
the values of x axis and y axis for the exact
location that it was clicked. So that is just
a great background information that you can go
ahead and do something with it. If you'd like
to. Now you can clearly see why this bind method
requires from us to receive one more parameter,
when we assign a function as a event that needs
to be called. Now it might be a great idea to
also prepare the bind method for our right
clicks. So I'm going to minimize this console.
And I'm just going to duplicate this line. And
I'm going to say that we should be also binding
the button dash three. So this will stand for
right click, and this will stand for left,
click. Now you might also want to try button dash
two if button dash three doesn't work for you.
Just for safety. If three doesn't work when
you right click three, also button dash two.
If you have any further troubles, then let
me know this in the comment section. Alright,
so I'm going to say here, right click Actions.
And obviously, I'm going to go here and say
this right click Actions. And again, I'm going
to receive this event. And I'm just going to
do the same right. So at first I'm going to print
the event. And I'm going to say I am right click,
so we can differentiate between the two. And
I'm going to again, execute our game. And I know
we can see this, but I'm going to right click
on that. And you can see that now we have the
text in the console. That is the exact same like
the right click actions. So that is great. And
we were able to actually assign some events
to all of our buttons dynamically. Alright,
so in that episode, we are going to focus a lot
in our cell class, because we're going to need to
write some logic to prepare the Minesweeper game.
That's going to be very fun to write all of those
new attributes that we'd like to receive in
this cell class. And as well as writing all
the methods that will be responsible to
write the logic of our Minesweeper game.
So there's going to be a lot of object oriented
stuff that we're going to write in that episode.
And that's going to be very cool doing all
of those. Alright, so first things first, we
might want to start by increasing the size of our
buttons to make them more readable. And that is
achievable by going ahead to the instantiation of
our button class inside this Create button object,
and passing in some additional arguments that will
be responsible to really increase the size of our
buttons. Now, before preparing the project,
I figured out that passing in width equals to
12. And height equals two, four are great values.
When you play Minesweeper, where it has 36 cells,
now, you can actually go ahead and pass in
here some formula that will be responsible
to make the buttons smaller if the grid size
gets bigger. But in order to make that simple,
then I'm just going to leave it as it is. And
I'm going to assume throughout the tutorial,
that we are only going to play the Minesweeper
game with 36 buttons, meaning the grid size
being six, which is that value that I'm talking
about. So now I'm going to execute my main file.
And that's how it looks like right now. And
that's just bigger and more readable and more
comfortable to play with. Alright, so now that
we came up with this, then we are going to need
to take our next steps in order to have some more
info about each of our cells. Now, for example,
we don't have even one single indicator about
which cell is what, until now, because the only
thing that we know about each of our cells is
the fact that it is just writing a text in all
of those 36 buttons. But it could have been great
if we could have some indicators about each of our
cells in here. So for example, until this point,
we know that we have 36 buttons. So we have those,
and we have those, right, but we don't have
even one single indicator about each cell.
So for example, it could have been nice if this
cell, for example, could have an attribute like x
equals to zero and y equals to zero, because
that is just something that represents that cell
specifically, that means that we could receive
some more attributes in that cell in the same
goes, for example for that. So here, right, it
could have been great if we could say that this
cell had an attribute like x equals to five and
y equals to five. And the reason I use these five
and five in here, this because we start to count
from zero, so 012345 in the same counting method,
from the top to bottom, like that. So let's go
ahead and receive some more attributes in this
class. So I'm going to go to my init method, and
I'm going to say X and Y, like that and make sure
that you add those comments. And then I'm going
to use the self assignment self dot x equals to x,
then I'm going to do the same for self dot y,
self dot y is equal to y like that. And now
that I have this, then I can actually go ahead and
go to my main.py file and pass in those numbers,
because I iterate over those numbers when I create
those cells. So you can already see that we have
some problems instantiating the cell, because
we need to pass in some mandatory documents. And
once we do that, then we are totally fine. And now
that we have some attributes in each of our cells,
we can actually use those to temporarily display
different text on our cells. So we can change this
into a formatted string, for example, and we can
use the reference to self dot x comma self dot y
inside the curly brackets. And now I can execute
our game. And you can see that now we have some
attributes where each attribute represent a unique
sale, right, so we know that x equals to five y
equals to five is that sale here. And we know that
2.2 Is that sale over there. So that's a great
starting to prepare the algorithm that we want
to write to have the Minesweeper game. Alright,
so now that we have done this, then we want to
prepare designing, creating some minds between all
of those cells. Now we know that in a minesweeper
game, when we start each game, the game picks up
some random cells, and it converts them into cells
that are forbidden to click meaning minds. So we
need to somehow write an algorithm that will be
responsible to take a couple of cells and turn
them into minds. Now we know that we already
have an attribute that is called ease mind.
And by default, all of those are false. So now
we're going to need to write a method that will
pick up some cell objects. And we'll convert those
attributes from Bing is mine equals to false to is
mine equals to true, so that we will have a great
beginning of the Minesweeper game going on. Now,
we know that temporarily, all of the cells are mod
minds, because we always assign false but that's
something that we are going to change just right
now. So in order to start designing this, then
it's a great idea to have a static method, which
we can call from the main.py file, right after
we instantiate the sale objects. So it's a great
idea to just have a method that is not belong to
each instance, besides it is belongs globally to
the class. And that's the definition of a static
method. So I'm going to use that decorator
or static method. And I'm going to say def,
randomize mines, like that. So this means that
it takes a couple of cells and turns them into
mines. So that is exactly where we'd like
to write some logic to turn some cells into
mines. So temporarily, I'm going to pass in the
past, so we will not have any arrows. And now
let's see how we are going to do that. All right.
So first things first, we need to understand how
we can store all of our instances inside the list.
And there is a great reason that we want to do
that in that stage, because we instantiate 36
instances, but we don't have any control how we
can take further actions with those 36 instances
that we instantiate from this sell class that we
have here. So in order to have a collection of all
of our instances in one place, then it is a great
idea to create a class attribute inside our cell
class, which we can name something like all. And
that's going to be a an empty list temporarily.
Now we're going to append the objects of the cell
class to that all variable. And that's something
that we can do dynamically inside our init method,
because this method is the method that is being
called every time that you create an instance.
So it totally makes sense to go ahead and do
here something that will be responsible to append
the object to the cell dot all list.
So we can have all the instances
of this cell class in one place. And that means
that we're going to need to say here, cell
dot all. Now that's the way that you can access
class attributes inside your class, you might have
thought about using jest all. But when we work
with classes, you always need to specify the
class name as a prefix when you access your class
attributes. So we can say cell dot all dot append,
and then we could add the object itself, which
is self. So now that we have done this, then we
probably like to test if that is something that's
going to work. So we can go to our main.py file.
And right after we instantiate all of those
objects in those lines, we can say print
cell dot all. So we should see a list with 36
elements inside this, also here. So you can see
that this is exactly the result, you will see that
we have probably told the six elements in here
that also we can test. With using the len built
in function. Before that, you can see that we have
36. Now you'll probably notice that the objects,
the way that the objects were represented in the
console was not too much friendly, it could have
been great if we could override the setting, that
we could see the objects nicer and more friendly.
And that's something that we can do by overriding
some magic methods. So we can go to that soul
class. And we can override some magic method
that will be responsible to change the way that
the object is being represented. And I'm talking
about a magic method that is called our EPR. Like
that. So we can go ahead and say that this should
return a formatted string that could look
like the following cell. And then we will pass
in here self dot x and self dot y. So that's just
more friendly string that will represent each
object more friendly. So besides seeing random
IDs, then we can see real friendly names for each
of our objects. Next. And if we want to test that
this is going to work, I can again allow myself to
execute this main.py file and confirm that. And
you can see that now I have way more friendly
objects in here, you can see that we have perfect
result. All right, so now that we understood this,
then I want to work side by side, left side will
be the main.py file, and the right side will be
the sale.py file. Now, I want to check out each
time that I'm doing a great job in writing some
logic inside this randomized mines. So I'm going
to go ahead and right after I instantiate those,
I'm going to call this randomize minds
static method. So I'm going to say cell that
randomize minds like that. And I'm going to
leave it as it is, and every time that I add
a piece of code inside this method, then I
want to execute the entire game to see that
I did not screw up anything. All right, so first
things first, in order to randomize the things,
in order to pick some random things from a
collection, we need to work with the library
that is called random. So I'm going to go to
the first line here, I mean to the second line,
and I'm going to say here, import random.
Now, random has a very specific method that
is responsible to pick randomly some elements
from the given collection. Now I'm going
to show a simpler example at first. So I'm
going to go here and say that I have a list.
And again, that's going to be just a simple
example, to show you how that method I'm talking
about works. So I'm going to have a list with
three names. All right, we're going to have Jim,
Michael and Paul. And then let's say
that I want to randomly pick two names
each time. So I'm going to go ahead and say random
dot simple, simple is a method that at first
accepts the collection that you want to pick
randomly elements from, so it will be my list.
And then the second argument is the amount of
elements that you want to pick each time. So
since I want to pick two names each
time, then I'm going to pass in here,
too. So let's also assign this entire statement
to a variable. So I'm going to call this
picked names, right, and then I'm going to just
print it. So print picked names. Now pay attention
that I call this method. So we should be seeing
the results when I execute this game. So when I
go ahead and execute our program, then you can see
that I receive Jim and Michael. And for our next
one, we can totally receive different names, you
can see that this time I received Jean and Paul.
So that's exactly what we want to do with our
minds, we want to randomly pick some cells,
some silver objects, and then just change the
attributes of ease mind to true because all of
them are false. So now that we understood this,
let's go ahead and write the needed logic inside
the randomized minds. So my list is going to
be sale dot all because that is the collection
that I want to pick some objects randomly from
it, right. So I'm going to delete this line
right after we understood how the sample works,
I'm going to change this variable to picked cells.
Because that is just a more realistic variable
name. And then I'm going to delete this line
temporarily, we're going to jump a line here. So
it will be easier to see the arguments that are
passed. And the collection that I will be passing
here will be filled out all because the cell dot
all includes all the instances, right, and then
we need to decide the form an integer, which
will be responsible to be the element count that
should be picked. Now, if we have about 36 cells,
then it might be a great idea to pick at least as
a quarter of a value of it. So maybe nine cells
to convert them into a mine will not make this
game too much difficult to to basically win it
right. So I'm going to pass in here nine
temporarily just to see how that is going
to work. Then I'm going to say print picked
cells and execute our program. And then you
can see that we have randomly nine cell
objects that have been picked in here.
So that's an extremely useful method
that we can go ahead and use it to
pick up some cells and convert them into minds.
So now that we have a picked cells collection,
meaning get picked cells list, then we can
actually iterate over the picked cells objects,
and only changing the attribute of is mine from
false to true. So let's go ahead and besides print
pixels, use a for loop that will look like the
following. So I can say for pixel in pixels.
And then now I'm iterating over each object. So I
can say pixel.is. Underscore mind equals to true.
Now, the ease mine is coming from here, because
we already know that we have such an attribute.
And we just want to change that to true. And now
that we have this, then let's go ahead and run
our program. And we should not be seeing anything
but in the background, the attribute has been
totally overridden by the value of true. Now if
you really want to test that, you can go ahead and
after calling the randomize minds in the left
side, you can go ahead and use something like
for C in cell dot all then print the c.is
mine. So we should be seeing some truths,
some falses. And that's going to be the final
testing, that will really show us that we were
able to change some attributes. And you can see
that this is exactly the result. So we have done
a great job picking up some random objects, and
just turn them into minds. And that's just a one
way that you can do that. Okay, so now that we
have done this, then it totally makes sense to
delete those sorts of debug lines. Now we need to
figure out how we are going to be dynamic deciding
the value of this picked minds amount, right,
so we can go ahead and use the settings.py file
to actually use some formula to calculate how many
minds we want in our game. So we can go ahead and
use here one more setting that we can name minds
count in that might be equal to something like the
following. So I will open up the parentheses and
I will say between those read size power of two,
and then I can divide it by four. Because in that
game, currently, we have totally six cells because
we iterate over the value of six, two times.
So it makes sense that we write such a formula,
right, so six power of two divided by four is
nine. And that is pretty much the value that
we look to have, when we want to have at least
a fair Minesweeper game, we don't want to have
half of the value, we don't want to have like
27 minds, because that's just going to be
too difficult to to win that game. So about a
quarter of that value is just fine. Now, you
might also ask yourself, what is going to happen
if one day I will change the grid size to seven.
So seven power of two is 49. And divided by
four is 12. Point 25. And that is just not
good, because mine's count will be an integer. So
I'm just going to add here one more first slash.
And when you use double first slash,
it is forcing it to be in an integer,
it totally ignores the remainder. So we can just
add here, one more frost slash, and that will be
okay. Now I can go back to my cell.py file, and I
can refer to that value settings that mines count.
And I see that we don't have any input line about
the settings. So I can just go ahead and use input
settings up top, and we should be fine. All right,
so in that episode, we are going to design what we
should do when we left click on a cell. So first
things first, we should be deleting the text that
we have wrote to each of the cells here, which
represents the x and y axis values. So let's go
ahead and delete this first. So I'm going to take
that line off because this used to be the text of
the cell. So I'm just going to make that we equal
to nothing. And then we need to decide what we're
going to display here. Once we left click on a
cell. So let me re execute the game like that.
And now we can see that we don't have anything.
So the expected reaction here is whenever we click
left click excuse me on their cell, then
we should be displaying a number, which
that number will represent how many minds there
are surrounded that cell. So what that means,
it means that if that's a mine, and that's a
mine, and as well as this one, then we should
be displaying here, three, because this cell
should figure out how many mines there are
surrounding that cell. Let's take one more example
here. So let's assume that we clicked here,
right? Then this cell should start thinking how
many minds there are surrounded the cells. So
this means we talk about all those cells.
And let's say that we have a mind here,
right? We have one mind there, and all of
those are not mine. So we should be displaying
here. One, right? So that's going to be the main
goal in that episode. And it's going to take a
lot of algorithms that we We'll be writing inside
methods inside the cell class. So it's going to be
extremely challenging and also fun doing that.
And let's go ahead and get started. Alright,
so I'm going to start by scrolling down to
the left click Actions. And then I'm going
to delete everything here and start writing here
some actions that we need to take. Now one of the
first things that we're going to write here is
an if conditional that will check if that cell
is actually in mind. And I can do that by writing
if self.is Mine. So the reason that I can do that
is because I know that in the beginning of the
game, I already call this method that is called
randomize mines, which takes a couple of soul
objects, and then it sets is mine equals to true,
so I can totally do that. And then if the click
cell is a mind, then I want to start taking
several actions. So those several actions are also
going to be located under a method that we can
write right now. So if self.is Mine, then I can
go ahead and say self dot show underscore mind,
something like that. And that is just a theory.
I know that show mine is not a method that exists
right now. But that's what we're going to do just
right, now I'm going to go out of that method. And
then I'm going to say def, show mine. And I will
receive self as a parameter for sure. All right,
so in that method, I am going to basically write
the actions that will be responsible to display
this cell as a mind. Now we know that here,
we should write a logic to interrupt the game
and display a message, a message, that player
lost, right, something like that. But I'm not
going to do that temporarily, because it is going
to be too much, I'm going to stop and terminate
the game every time that I click on a mine while
we develop that game. So converting the background
of that cell into a red background color should
be enough temporarily. So I'm going to just say,
here's something like the following self dot cell,
underscore bottom object, and then I'm going to
configure the background color of it. So if you
remember, when we use TK inter objects, we can use
this configure method which will be responsible
to configure our elements. So as an example, I can
go ahead and say here, Bg equals to red. Now, that
is equivalent to what we have done with the frame.
Let me show you that by splitting vertically,
you can see that we took our window here,
and we used dot configure BG equals to black.
So what we do here, we do here an action that is
quite equivalent. Whenever we click on a cell, we
check if that is a mine. And if it is, then we'll
launch that method, which will be responsible to
configure the background color of that to red.
And that is just a perfect beginning. So if we
run our game, and we click on a couple of cells,
then you can see that this is a mine. So that's
why it has been colored to red. So that's a great
start. And I realized that I had a typing mistake
here. So this will be logic to interrupt the game.
And display missing display will last all right.
So now that we have done this, then we should be
also designing what we shall do if the cell is
not in mind. So here is the exact location that
I should be say else. And then I should launch a
method that will say self dot show underscore, CIL
right, and here is going to be the complex stuff
because we need to display a number that will
represent the amount of minds that are surrounded
the click cell. So I'm going to go here,
and I'm going to in and out from this left click
Actions. And I'm going to say here, def show,
underscore Sal and we will receive yourself,
let's say pass here and explain what we're going
to do here just in a second. Now I zoomed
out a bit to the beginning of our class,
because in order to explain what we should do now
I'm going to again, bring back the text that we
used to have here, which was self dot x comma
self dot y because I want to display the axis x
and x is y values, because that's going to be
helpful to explain what I'm about to explain right
now. So I execute the game here, you can see that
again, we have the x's, x and y values. Now in
order to start calculating the amount of mines in
the surrounded cells, whenever we click somewhere,
then we should be using those x's, x and y values
for sure. Because think about the situation that
we clicked here, right? Let's say that we clicked
here right now. So we should start iterating over
the cells that are surrounding that cell and
check if each one of those are mines or not.
And then somehow we should be collecting
In the amount of minds and displayed here,
so that's a lot of actions that we should be
taking. Now we can understand that having a method
that will receive the x and y as a parameter,
and then will give us back the object of a soul
is going to be extremely helpful, because I
think of a situation that you click on that. So
you want to check the attributes of this cell of
that cell, and also this cell. So we can already
start understanding that, if we will have a method
that will return the cell object, depending on the
given x and y values is going to be extremely,
extremely helpful. So that's going to be the
first step that we should be taking right now, we
should be writing a method that we can call it get
cell by exes. And then this will return us back
in object of the cell. So let's go ahead and write
that. Alright, so I'm going to go here to that
line above the show cell. And I'm going to say
something like this, get cell by Asus,
and then I'm going to receive here,
x and y, like that. And the actions that we want
to do here is basically return a single object
based on the values of x and y. That's all
that's everything that we want to do here
in this method. So now, we know that we have this
list that is called all and we can basically start
iterating over this list of objects to find the
sale object that we need based on those x and y
values. So I'm going to go ahead and start with a
basic filtration that will help us to give us back
the cell object that we need. So I'm going to
say here for cell in cell dot all and just pay
attention that I'm using the class name, so c
should be in uppercase. And then I'm going to
say something like the following. If so dot x
is equal to do given its argument and sell dot y
is equal to the given y value, then we should
be using here return cell like that. Now, the
reason that I can do this is because whenever I'm
going to have a match in those x and y attributes,
then I can immediately stop my iteration and
just return that object. And that's going to
be helpful, because whenever we want to display
the cell, then we immediately want to see what is
going on inside the surrounding cells. So that's
a method that is going to be really helpful again,
and that's going to be something that we are going
to understand in a couple of minutes. All right,
so the next thing that I want to do now is to call
that method and basically print the result of that
inside the show sell. Now just a kind reminder,
if we take a look in the left click Actions,
if the cleat sale is not in mind, we are entering
here in the URL statement and we call this short
sale method. So if we go here and say print, self
dot get sale by xs, and we pass in just random
values, like I don't know zero, comma zero,
then we should see the object specifically,
where the X attribute is equal to zero and the
Y attribute is equal to zero. And that is not
going to be a matter which So I'm clicking
here because I just bring the object where x
and y are equal to zero both. All right, so let me
launch the game now and see what is going on here.
So if the click cell is not the mind,
then we should see the object right. So
let me make the console bigger. And I'm just going
to click on 05. And that was a mine. So we did not
see anything on the console. Let's click on here.
And you can see that I see the object still zero,
comma zero, and that was a mind going to click
here. This is a mine as well, that's not a mine.
So that is a perfect result. I'm also going to
click here, you can see that we have a perfect
method that returns the object based on the given
x and y values. So let me show you in a separated
window, why that's going to be helpful having such
a method. So imagine again, that we are going to
click on 1.1 As an example, right? So we're going
to need to collect all those eight cells that are
surrounded the Clicktale. So this means that now
we have the control to bring this one that one
and this and that and this in that and also those
two here. So in order to show what we should be
doing right now with the gate sell by access
method. Then I'm going to work on this side note
pad that I have here. So let's imagine a situation
that we really clicked on 1.1. So if we click on
1.1, then we should be bringing the cells that
are 0.0 0.1 0.2. Right. So those are going to be
those three, right. And then let's continue
on. So we should be also bringing 1.0,
and 2.0. And those are going to be those
two. And let's continue on for again,
clicking on 1.1, we should be also bringing the
sale of 2.1 2.2. And those are just going to be
those two. And then we also have 1.2, that we
should bring. And that's going to be also written
here. So you can see that we have a formula that
we should be following. So now let's go ahead and
implement this in our code. So I'm going to delete
all the drawings here. And I'm going to go back
to our actual code. So first things first, I'm
going to delete this one. And then I'm going to
just do something like the following, I'm going to
make a list that is going to be called surrounded
cells. And that's going to be equal to a list. And
that list is going to include those eight objects.
Now those eight objects could be basically pulled
from this get cell by exes method. So first,
it's going to be served dot get cell by exes. And
for 1.1, we should be decreasing the x by one,
and we should be also decreasing the Y by one.
So first one is going to be self dot x minus one,
the second value is going to be self dot y minus
one like that. So we can allow ourselves to
check the first cell that we should be pulling,
right. So let's go to the second one. And don't
forget to add here a comma, because we have a
list that is going to include eight elements
and we should be comma separating them. So the
second one is going to be self dot get sale by
axis. And now the formula is going
to be decreasing the x by one.
And the y value is going to be the same because as
you can see the y value here in the here are the
same. So I'm just going to pass in here self dot
y, and again, comma separated. And in order to be
organized, I'm also going to say here, V to market
as a checked, so So the third one is going to be
sold out get sell by axis. And again, the self dot
x is going to be decreased by one. But this time,
the y value is going to be increased by one
because that is true here. So this is now also
checked, I met I'm going to add here a comma. And
now I'm going to say self dot get sold by axis,
I'm going to pass in the same self dot x because
the next value is one, and then the y value is
decreased by one. So it's going to be self dot
y minus one like that. And that's also checked.
And now I'm going to jump on to the next one,
it's going to be get sold by exes self dot x
plus one because the next one is 2.0. And then
I'm going to pass here self dot y minus one,
right, and that's the fifth value, going
to check that the sixth one is going to be
so the previous one was the fifth value. And
that is that's going to be the sixth value.
So self dot x plus one again, and the y value
should be the same. Going to close that add the
comma market as a checked. So I'm going to do
this two more times self dot get sale by axis.
Now we can pay attention that both x and y values
are increased by one. So I'm going to do exactly
like that. Plus one for both. And then the last
value is going to be self dot gets held by axis,
we're going to be passing the same x value, and
then the self dot y is going to be increased by
one. And we can allow ourselves to basically write
a check for all the eight cells. So now that we
have done this, then we can allow ourselves to
first print it to see if we have done a great
job right. So I'm going to say print surrounded
cells to see that we have done a wonderful job.
And let's go ahead and check ourselves. So
I'm going to execute game Stop and rerun. So,
we are going to click on 1.1. And we
should be see a list with eight objects.
Let's follow up what is going on here. So
00 0.1 0.2 1.0 2.0 2.1 2.2, and 1.2. So
perfect, right? Perfect job, we brought everything
that we need. And if we count this 12345678,
it really seems like we have done a wonderful job.
Now, the problematic thing could be if we click on
a sale like 0.0, because this has three surrounded
sales. So this might lead to not working. But
let's see if that's going to work, I believe it's
going to work. And it is going to pull the three
objects like expected 1.0 0.1, and 1.1. So I'm
going to click on 0.0. And you can see that that
is quite what's happening. But you can see that
we receive none for all the five, because what
is going on here, if we click on 0.0, then at some
point, this gate cell by axis is going to receive
negative values, because whenever we click on
0.0, then a minus one value could be passed.
So we need to eliminate those nuns when we
write the surrounded sales list. And that's
something that we're going to take care of later
on. But until now a perfect job bringing on the
surrounded cell objects. And let's continue from
here. Alright, so now that we have done this, then
we said a minute ago that we're going to take care
of the non values that we had inside our list.
Now that is something that could be done by list
comprehension. Now a list comprehension means
to create a list by a one liner, that is going
to immediately take care of something that you
want to take care of right now. So in order to
take care of eliminating the non values inside
the list, then you can use a list comprehension
expression in order to handle the non values and
just get them out of your list. So what we are
going to do now is we are going to override the
surrounded sales list. But we're going to need
to use a one liner list comprehension, you know,
to eliminate the nonce, so that's going to be
something like the following. So surrounded cells
is going to be equal to a new list, which is going
to look like the following. So what we really want
to do is to have the exact same list, but we want
to eliminate the nuns. So that is achievable by
doing something like that. So you can use a one
liner for loop inside your list in order to take
care of something immediately. For example, let me
show you how we can do a for loop in one line. So
you can say cell for cell in surrounded cells. And
now that we have done this, let's see the results.
Right, so I'm going to print surrounded cells
and pay attention that I'm overriding the value
of this one by again using the same value and
assigning something new to that. So I'm going
to again, execute our main.py. And let's show what
is going to happen if we click on 1.1, you can see
that result is pretty much the same. And if I was
to click on 0.0, then again, the results are same.
But whenever you use a list comprehension, and
you include inside of that a one liner for loop,
then you can use an if statement, that will take
care of something that you don't want right now.
So I can go ahead and use an expression here that
will look like if sale, meaning the iterator value
is not known. So that's going to eliminate out our
non values. And that is exactly what we want. So
again, I can re execute our program, and
see if that's going to work. So if we were
to click on 0.0, we see the perfect result,
right, we see three elements inside our list.
And that's also something that we may want
to test with Excel like 0.1. Because if we
count the surrounding cells, then we have here
1234, and five. So if we click on that, then you
can see we have five elements inside our list. So
that is a perfect way of bringing the surrounding
sales when we click on some sale. Alright, so now
that we understood this, then I'm going to move
all those lines of code into a separated method
so that we could have a property that is going
to represent the surrounded sales object. Now
a property is basically like an attribute that
is read only. And you can mark those attributes
as read only attributes by using a decorator. So
let me show you how that's going to work. So I'm
going to Just copy everything from here. And you
know what, just cut it like CTRL X and not copy.
And then I'm going to say this surrounded cells,
and this will receive itself. And I'm just going
to leave those code snippets here. And then I'm
going to say something like, return sales. And
I'm going to be changing those variable names to
sales, and also this one. And as well as that one.
Now, the reason that I'm doing this, it is because
I don't want to have the same variable name as the
same as the name of my method, because that could
lead to a lot of problems. And I said that I will
be converting this into a read only attribute.
And that's achievable by the property, they call
this. So above this method, I'm going to say add
property. And now you can just use it as an
attribute exactly like the attributes that we have
here in the in it. So now that we have done this,
then I can allow myself to go back to show sell,
and validate that I have done a great job. And I
can use here self dot surrounded sales. And you
can see that I have an auto completion. And that
is just perfect. Now I can access my surrounded
cells by accessing this property from here. All
right, so now that we have a method that brings
in the surrounded sales objects, then we need to
iterate over the surrounded sales objects, and
identify which one of those are mines, and which
of those are not mines. So that's going to be
taking in one more method that is going to be
responsible for that. So I'm going to again,
create a method here that is going to
look like surrounded sills mines linked,
and you can understand what this method is going
to do, it is going to count the minds that are in
the surrounded cells whenever a cell is clicked.
So I'm going to make this logic as easy as saying
first counter equals to zero. And then I'm going
to iterate over the surrounding sales objects. So
it's going to be for cell in self dot surrounded
cells. And I'm going to check if cell.is
underscore mine, then I'm going to increase the
counter by one. So it's going to be countered,
plus equals one. And at the end of the
day, I want to return the counter back
and just use it. So it's going to be getting out
of those four loops. And if conditional, and then
just use return counter like that. Now, just like
we have done with the self dot surrounded cells,
I can also allow myself to use the surrounded
cells mines linked as a read only attribute.
So I'm again going to go above this method. And
I'm going to mark it as a property like that
by using this decorator. Now, I did not mention
this early on. But if you don't know what is the
property decorator, then I have an object oriented
programming series that you can go ahead and take
a look. And I bet that it is going to be a very
informative video if you never heard about this
property decorator, which is an extremely useful
thing when we write object oriented programs.
Alright, so now that we have done this, then I can
allow myself to do something like the following.
So I want to go inside the show cell. And I just
want to be seeing the length of the minds meaning
the amount of minds that I have, whenever I click
on a cell, so that is just going to be a great
test for our game. So if we click on a cell, then
we can allow us to print so of that surrounded
sales minds length. And let's go ahead and see if
that's going to work. So I'm going to execute my
game. And for example, let's assume that I'm going
to click on 0.0. And that is a mine and I'm fine
with it. And that's also a mind. And let's click
on here. So you can see that I see three in the
console, right, because I clicked on the 1.1. And
what that means, it means that over here we have
three minds. So let's keep on and continue
clicking on some cells. So we already have
two minds here and we shouldn't be having one
more inside the surrounding cells. So not here,
not here. Not here, not here. Also not here. Okay,
so we have a mind here. And if we click on here,
so that's not the mind as well. So that is
perfect. That is really perfect. Because a round
this one around this one. So here we have
three minds. And this means that we have
completed writing this logic in the best way
that we can. Alright, so there is going to be
one more thing that we want to do immediately
when we go ahead and click on a cell and that's
going to be displaying the num Have mines that are
surrounded that sell. So now that we have control
with the surrounded sales mines linked, then we
can allow ourselves to change the behavior of
this show sole method. And we can go ahead and
just configure the text of our cell to display
the amount of minds surrounded that so so that's
going to be something like the following is going
to be by accessing to the sell button object and
configuring the text. So I'm going to use the
Configure method again. And I'm just going to say
text is equal to self dot surrounded cells mines
length. And that should be enough. And now I can
really allow myself to delete the original text
that we had previously. So I'm going to scroll
up, and I'm going to go back to the metal that
helps us to create the button object. And
I'm going to take off this text from here,
just delete that. And then I'm going to execute
our game, run the program. And let's click on
some cells. So you can see that we have
to, and this means that we have a cell,
maybe here, that is not the mind. So this means
that for sure that is a mind and that's a minor
as well. So perfect. Now we really start to have
a real game going on. In that is pretty much what
we want to do. In that tutorial, we want to write
the logic to display the amount of minds that are
located in the surrounded cells whenever we click
on a cell. So in this episode, we are going to
design some functionalities that will be helpful
to display more information about the game. For
example, currently, we know that there are 36
cells that are clickable that we can click on.
But now if I click here, we know that we have
35 cells that we can click, so we need to
interactively display this kind of information in
our window, that's going to be interesting to see
how we can develop such a functionality. And in
addition, we are going to develop a functionality
that will be responsible to automatically open
all the surrounding cells. If the clicked cell
length is zero, exactly like in this case. Because
obviously, if we know that there are zero mines
surrounding the cell, then there is no point
to not automatically click on this and that
and this and that and that. So the reason for
that is because there are always going to be
zero minds surrounding that sales. So to click
on them is safe. So we are going to develop a
functionality that will do this automatically for
us, and it will improve the speed of our game. So
let's go ahead and get started by developing
everything that we just said here. Alright,
so let's start with the second point that
I have mentioned earlier. And that's going
to be how to automatically open the surrounded
cells in case we see the number of zero when we
click on some cell. So if we were to
take a look in the left click Actions,
then you can see that we have a separation between
a cell that is actually a mine to a cell that is
not a mine. So here we can actually check if the
clicked cell is not mine, for sure. So this means
that our code is going to be here. But we can
also check if the display number is zero or not.
And the way that we can do this is by using
the property of surrounded cells minds length,
and we can verify if that is equal to zero or not.
So that's going to look like the following. So if
self dot surrounded cells minds length is equal
to zero, then we should do something. So if we are
going to enter here, then we want to launch a for
loop that will be responsible to basically display
the minds length for all the surrounded cells.
Now we already know that we have a property that
returns us back at least with all the surrounded
save objects. And that comes from here. So we are
going to use this in that case for sure. So that's
going to be like the following. So we can say
for sale underscore object in self dot surrounded
cells. And we can go ahead and say something like
cell object, dot show underscore cell. Now
if you remember, we have a method as well,
that is called Show cell which we call here.
So it makes sense to try to open all the cells
that are surrounded the click cell, and also
calling the show sale method for them as well.
And that's going to work in case of course,
if the minds length is zero, so let's launch
the game and see if we have the expected behavior
here. So the expected behavior here is if we click
here, and that displays zero, then the game should
automatically open that in that and that and let's
see if we have this. So I'm I'm going to read
Let's try to click here and you can see that
we have two. So that's not a good test for us.
And that's a mine. So we are looking for zero.
And you can see that this works perfectly, you can
see that once I clicked on zero, then we got all
the numbers that are surrounded the click cell
in the first stage. So that's something that is
going to speed the game and going to be extremely
helpful. And let's continue from here. Alright,
so now that we have done this, then let's go ahead
and see how we can add some more elements to our
window. Now, we said that we'd like to display
some more information about the game that we play,
for example, information, like how many cells left
in the game in every situation, because every time
you click on a cell, then the amount of cells
that left decreases, so let's go ahead and show
some text about that. Because that's going to be
helpful to see in what situation of game we are
currently at. So the approach of that is going
to be quite equivalent to what we have done with
Create button object. Now, if you remember,
we used an instance method that goes ahead
and creates a button. And then we go ahead and use
this last line here, which is looking like self
dot sell button object equals to btn, which will
be the variable that has this button object store.
So we are going to do pretty much the same thing.
When it comes to display the amount of sales that
left in the game, we are going to create a method
that will create some text element in the window.
And then we are going to call this method from the
main.py. File. And let's go ahead and start with
this. So I'm going to go ahead and say def, create
cell count, labeled. Now the reason that I'm using
label, it is because the name of the class
that are responsible to display just text
without any special functionality is called label.
And that's going to be the class that we're going
to initialize. So that is the reason I can allow
myself to call this function, I mean the method
the way it is. So we're also going to receive
here, another parameter that we can name location,
and I'm going to go inside of it. And I'm going to
say label, or LBL to make it shorter is equal to
a label. Now we know that we do not import this.
So I'm going to scroll here, and I'm going to say
from TK inter Import button and label as well. And
now that we have done this, then I'm going to pass
in the location argument. And then I'm going to
pass in some additional arguments. So this label
element accepts a parameter that is called text,
like we have seen with the button. And we can go
ahead and say that it's text could be a formatted
string, like cells left, and let's use a colon,
and then I can go ahead and use something like the
following, I can refer to the amount of cells that
we already know from the settings. So settings
dot grid size, and if I remember correctly, grid
size stores six in here, because we just set it
to six. And so it means that we have six times six
cells. So it makes sense to also use here one
more variable that we can name cell count.
And that will be equal to read size power of
two like that. So we can go ahead and as well
as replace this with that one. And that makes
totally sense. And now I can go ahead to my
cell.py file and replace this with cell count. Now
things are looking a lot better. So now that we
have done this, then let's go ahead and as well
as return the label object that we have here.
And now let's see how we are going to call this
from the main.py file. Now there is something
that is quite tricky with this method. And that
is the fact that this label is not something that
needs to be belongs to each of our cells, because
that is a general information about the game. So
what that means it means that this cannot be
an instance method. Because this is just a one
time method that we want to call throughout
the game, we do not want to call this method
for each cell object. So that's why this needs
to be a static method. And a static method is a
method that is just for use case of the class and
not for the use case of the instance. So that's
why it makes sense to mark it as a static method.
Now this also means that we should delete the self
because we do not need to receive the self if
we do not use an instance method. So now it's
safe to remove this from here and have a metal I'd
like the following. Now, if you never heard about
static methods, then there's actually an episode
about static methods in the Python op series that
I published recently on my channel. So be sure
to watch it at least for a couple of minutes,
in order to have a better understanding about
static methods. Alright, so now that we have done
this, then let's figure out where we are going to
call this method. Now, if you remember, for the
button object, we basically used a statement that
looked like the following. So we said that at the
beginning, self dot sale button object is equal
to none. And then we went ahead and we assign this
to a button object that is coming from here. So
we are going to do the same thing for the cell
count label, because that is going to be helpful
when we need to make use of the cell count label
from the main.py file. So now I can go ahead and
create an attribute that's going to be belongs to
the class level, not to the instance level. And
the reason that I'm doing this, it is because
the cell count label should be something that is
global should be something that is not belonged
to the instance level. So I'm going to go ahead
and say cell count label is equal to none. And
I can actually add here on the score object
to keep the same convention like the sell
button object. And now that I have done this, then
I can change this thing here to something like
cell, that cell count label object is equal to
LBL, which is the variable name that we use.
So that actually is quite equivalent to what
we have done previously throughout the series
with the sell button object. And now that we have
this, then we can go ahead and use this from the
main.py, like the following. So I can go ahead
to here. And I can just call this. So I'm going
to go ahead and say comment, like call the label
from the cell class. And this should look like
this. So we can say cell dot create. So count
label, and the location for that will be the left
frame. Now, left frame is the frame that is used
to be stalled in the left area of our window. Now,
if you remember, let me show you that it's going
to be right here in that location. So if I'm
drawing here, something, then this is the top
frame. This is the left frame. And this whole
area is the game frame, the center frame that
we use it to play the game. So the widget that
I'm talking about should be here. Alright, so
let me clean that and close the game. Right. So
now we call this method. So this means that I
can access the label object by referring to cell
dot cell count label object. And I can just use
here a place in order to place this in somewhere
in the frame. And let's start by placing this
in 0x equals to zero and y equals to zero. Now,
if you remember, the numbers are relative to the
frame itself. So this will be in the first pixel
of the cell of the left frame, excuse me. So if
I run the main.py file, then you can see that
we have this here. Now I know that it is quite
small, and it needs some edits to make it bigger
and nicer. So that's exactly what we're going
to do now. So if we go back to the cell.py file,
and we go inside our static method, which creates
the label, then we can go ahead and increase the
width and the height. So let's go ahead and use
width equals to 12. And height is equal to four,
exactly like the numbers of our button.
And let's also give these attributes
like BG, meaning the background color is equal to
blue black. And we can use the foreground color
parameter as well. So we can use f g is equal
to white. And let's see what is going to happen
now. So if we were to run the game, there, you
can see that this is not quite changing. So this
means that maybe we need to increase the font,
environmental here, so we can go ahead and use
font is equals to something like the following.
So formed by default accepts a tupple. So the
first argument of this of these should be the
font type. And you can go ahead and play around
with your favorite fonts. And the second one
should be the size of the font. So I'm going
to start by size of maybe for the eighth, see
if that's going to be too much and that is,
so I'm going to change the to maybe 30. And that
looks just perfect right now. So I'm going to
leave it as it is. This means that we can delete
those attributes and continue from here. Alright,
so now that we understood this, then let's see
how we are going to interactively change the
text. Every time that we click on a cell in the
clicked cell was actually a cell and not in mind,
that finishes the game. So this means that we need
to change the amount of cells left in the text
that we have located in the left frame. So this
means that we should be doing this exact action
in the method that we have named show SIL.
And the reason that we want to do this here
is because that is the perfect location that
uses some actions when we click on some cell,
and that is actually a cell a regular cell, that
is not a mine. So this is the exact location that
we look to take some actions when we want to
display regular information about an open cell.
So I'm going to use here a comment that will
say, replace the text of cell count label with
the knee word count, something like that. Now,
in order to test this out, then I'm going to
change this to something that is hard coded,
just to see that we are able to do this
successfully. So let's go ahead and test this
out. So at first, it makes sense to check if
cell, that cell count label object is none or
not. And I can just do it the way it is, if
cell that cell count label object should be enough
to test if this object is none, or is filled with
some information, meaning a label object. So
if it is, then we want to go ahead and use
cell, that cell count label object, and we want to
configure its text to a newer text. So in order to
test this, then let's go ahead and use changed
like that, and see how it is going to behave.
If I am running that and clicking on a random
location, then you can see that we see a change.
And that is perfect. So this will be the way that
this is going to work. Okay, so in that stage,
let's try to understand what will be the most
efficient way to store continuously the cells
that are left in the game. So first things first,
we could allow ourselves to store one more class
attribute that we can name cell count. Now,
we know that the cell count changes every time
that the show cell method is being called. So
what that means it means that every time that
show sale is being called, we could basically
decrease the amount of sales by one.
So let me show you how this could look like.
So we could go and scroll up and create here,
a class attribute that we can name cell count,
which we can also allow ourselves to set this
value to Settings dot cell count. So it makes
sense to at first have the value of 36, for
example, for this class attribute. And we could
continuously decrease this value every time that
the show cell method is being called. So we could
go here and use as the first line, something like
cell dot cell count, minus equals one, and this
will be responsible to decrease the sale counter
by one. And now that we are doing this, then
we are also going to change the methodology
that we store the text in the label that
we have. Now, if you remember, we use to
store inside the label information about the
left cells meaning the settings, that cell count.
But now it makes sense to change the reference
of that to cell dot cell count like that, because
that's going to be the variable that we are going
to decrease in every time that we click on a cell.
So this means that having it like that is a better
idea. So now I can allow myself to copy this and
scroll down. And every time that show cell is
being cold, then I can configure continuously
this text with the following information. So
let me delete this from here. And actually jump
align. And between those parentheses, I'm going
to say text is equal to exactly the same thing.
And this needs to be configured every time a cell
is being clicked because we need to so called
refresh the information that is displayed in
that label. So now that we have done this,
then It is about time to test if that is going
to work, right. So if we launch our main.py file,
then let's see what is going to happen. So if we
click here, then you can see that the amount here
has been decreased. Now, it could have been great
if we will hit a cell that has zero surrounded
minds, to see if that is going to work properly as
well. So if we click here, you can see that this
yet works great. And this is 34 to 3233, excuse
me, and you can see that here we have a mismatch.
And that's happening, because it thinks that
it should also decrease the amounts for the
minds that are here as well. Now, again, let
me show you what happened here just right now.
So at first we clicked here, here, and then
here, right, and we saw a perfect behavior of
33 in there. But now we try to click here, but
the game thinks that those cells should be open
as well. And that's why not only that, it
decreased to 32. It also decreased by five,
because it decreased the amounts for this
in that in this in that. And this and that,
right. So it's important to handle this situation
with something that we can do just right now,
because that is a bug in our game. So let's clean
here and go ahead and see how we can handle this.
So the way that we can handle this is by setting
up a an attribute that is going to be belong to
each sale, that we can name something like ease
underscore opened. Now ease underscore open is
going to be a Boolean type of variable that we can
set by default to false. And every time that the
show cell is called based on that cell object,
we can convert this boolean variable into true,
and that will mark this cell as being opened.
And in that case, we can conditional our program
to only decrease the sale count if the sale is not
open yet. So let's go ahead and design the search
functionality. So I'm going to scroll up. And I'm
going to say here something like the following.
I'm going to say self.is underscore opened.
And I'm going to set this to false, because
in the beginning of the game, it makes sense to
say that each cell is not opened yet. And now
that we have done this, then every time that we
use the method of show cell, then right after we
finish all of our functions, then we can go ahead
and say something like self.is open, excuse me,
is equal to true like that. And let me use a
comment here that will say Mark decyl, as opened,
use it as the last line of this method, something
like the following should be enough to explain
why we are doing this right here. So now we
can allow ourselves to do something like the
following we can say if self.is open,
and we actually want to test if that is
not open. So this means that I'm going to add
here, not. So this is going to check if the sale
is not open yet. And if that is the case, then I
want to indent everything inside this conditional,
because the only case that I want to execute
this, and this and as well as those lines
is in the case if the cell is not open
yet. So that is perfectly making sense to
use the code the way that we use it just right
now. So now that we have done all of this, then
let's test now if our game is going to behave as
expected. So I'm going to execute this main.py
file again. And I'm going to try to click on that
one. And that is a minus. So it makes sense that
the sales left is not decreasing, because we
should be finishing the game in that case, but we
did not want to do that because it will interrupt
our development process. So let's actually try to
execute our game one more time. And try to play
the game like it needs to be played. So you can
see that now we see two. So let's try to not
click here to not face with a mind. Try to
click here. So this is 34 still works perfect 33
And that's a mind so let's give it one more try.
If we click here, okay, perfect result because you
can see that we have now now nine cells opened and
this is decreased by nine. So let's test if that
is going to continue working great. So if we click
on those Free, then those are pretty safe because
we have zero here. So 2625 24. And you can see
that this works really perfect, because once we
click in here, it only decreased by two. And those
two, were for this one. And for that one. So now
we have a great game going on without any bugs.
And we handled a lot of things that could lead
to trouble in the future. Okay, so let's show
an example of what we want to do in that episode.
So if we run our game, and we start to play a bit,
and for example, we click here, we know that we
have three minds around there. But in order to
start figuring out what could be the minds, I
mean, the cells that you should not click on,
then you need some utility that will say to
yourself that you should not click on that
in the future. So it could have been nicer if we
could develop a future that will color the cell
in a different color. So we can differentiate
between the cells that we mark as mine candidates.
And that's exactly what we're going to design
in that episode. So the way that this feature
is going to work is by using the right click of
our mouse button. So if we are going to click
right click on a cell, then it is going to color
it with a color like orange, maybe some color that
will be a good color to differentiate between a
mind candidate to an actual mind that basically
leads us to lose the game. So it's basically going
to be something that will responsible to color the
cell with the given color. Now say that we clicked
on some location that we marked as mine candidate,
we also like to develop the opposite
action, which is going to be unmarked
the cell as a mind candidate. So those are both of
the functionalities that we are going to work just
right now. So let's go ahead and get started.
Okay, so the approach of doing something like
this, it is going to be pretty much similar to
what we have done with the EAS open the attribute,
we could first start with creating a new attribute
to each of our cell objects that will go something
like self thought is mine candidate, something
like that. And this value could be false for each
of our cells at first, the reason that this could
happen is because at first we never Mark ourselves
as mine candidates, we just start with a new blank
game. So now that we have such an attribute, it
makes sense to go ahead and take some actions when
we right click on a cell. And if you remember,
we already have a method that is called right
click Actions. And we could find this just by
scrolling down a bit, because this should be
right here. Okay, there it is. So here's the
exact location, that I could allow myself to
do something when we right click on a cell,
and one of the things that I can do is to
change the attribute from false to true. So
I can go ahead and say, if not self.is, mine
candidate. So I'm checking if the cell is
already not a mind candidate, then I can go ahead
and do some things. Now one of the first things
that I want to do is to change the background
color of the cell. So it is going to visually
mark it as a mind candidate. So it will be
self dot cell btn object dot Configure. And
we are going to call this method and I'm just
going to pass in here BG background color equals
to orange. And now that I have done this, I
can also allow myself to change from false
to true. So I can say self.is underscore mine
candidate equals to true like the following.
So now let's go ahead and test if that is going
to work for us. So I'm going to execute our game.
And I'm just going to right click on a cell.
And you can see that this works perfectly.
Now we said that we'd also like to design
the opposite action, which is just what we
are going to do now. And before we do that, I
want you to notice something important in here,
you will see that the sales left is not decreased.
And that is good because we did not open the sale,
right. So that's an important behavior that
we want to keep. So it doesn't matter how many
times we are going to click right click, it's good
that the sales left value is not decreasing here.
So that's something that I wanted to show up. All
right, so now that we have this, then we should
also design the opposite action by only saying
here else. So now we are doing something if the
cell is already a mind candidate. Now the next
time that we're going to right click on a cell,
and we know that the sale is mine candidate,
then we just want to do the opposite action. So
the opposite action will be to configure the color
to the original color. So will be served out sale
between object dot configure, we're going to call
this method. Now, this might be confusing here.
But there is a specific value for the
background color that you should specify,
that is already the default color for each of
the printer elements that you are creating. And
that is called system button phase. And that is
just the color that you see in the beginning,
right the kind of gray color. So that's
the reason that I am writing this thing
as the value of the BG. And then the next thing
that I'm going to do is obviously changing this
to false. So I'm going to say save that is my
candidate is equal to false like that. And that's
probably going to work without any surprises.
So if I'm right clicking one time, two times,
three times, then now let's try to undo our
actions. So I'm going to again, right click here,
and again here, and as well as here, you
can see that this work. So that's a great
start for having some mind candidates going on.
Now, let's also try to play the game with that,
right? See if we did something bad to rest
of our game. So that's a good test for us.
So I'm going to left click basically open
some cells. And you can see that this works,
can continue on clicking here, here
and there. And that's working great.
Now let's say that I think that this is a
mine here. So I'm just going to right click,
continue opening that. And as well as that one.
Now, this is actually a mind because for example,
if we take a look at this cell, right, you
can see that it's supposed to have one mind,
in here, here, here, here or there. So that's
the mind for sure. So that's good future now
that we can mark this as a mind candidate. So we
know that we should never click on that with the
left mouse click. Now I just wanted to remind
something that could lead you to some problems
using this mind candidate feature. I said earlier
in this series, that if you use button dash three,
like I did in here, then you might have some
problems, because in some males configurations,
it expects for button dash to, but since
I have the mouse wheel in my mouse,
then it should be button dash three for myself. So
if you notice that things are not working for you
pretty much as expected, then try to use other
combinations of numbers like two or even four,
just try to use something that is not three. And
I want to hope that it will work for you. Alright,
so now that we have done this, then let's go
ahead and design some final things that we want
in order to have the complete game. Now we already
know that we pretty much not finished the game,
when we actually click on our mind. So I'm going
to do something that will immediately warn a
message that we lost the game, if we click on a
mind. Now in order to do this, I'm going to assume
that you are working on a Windows machine. But the
way that you should quit again, with an exception
is really up to you. I'm just going to show one
example. But there are 10s of other options that
you can go ahead with it. And of course, since
I'm using a Windows machine, then this example
might be more fit for Windows environments.
Okay, so the first thing that I'm going to
do here is import some library that will be
responsible to throw a general message about how
we lost the game or something like that. So in
order to do that, I like the library that is
called C types. And that's just the library that
can help you to throw generic messages, warnings,
errors, any kind of things that you want to come
up with them. So now that we have this, then I'm
going to use this library and basically throw a
message if we open the mind. Now if you remember,
we have a method that is called Show mine.
And you'll see that we already have a comment
that says a logic to interrupt the game and
display a message that player lost. So here's
the exact location that we want to write such
a functionality. And that's what I'm about to
do right now. So if we delete this, now I'm going
to go ahead and just write a generic message. So
we are going to use this C types library,
and then I'm going to pick up the win DLL
sub library, and then I'm going to use the user
32 And then I'm going to say message box, W like
that. Now this is just a generic message box that
I'm going to throw out alright, so I'm going to
pass in here several arguments. And once we see
the result then I will explain why I did that.
Okay, so I will start by saying zero and then I
will say you clicked on a mind and I will pass in
one more string that will look like game over and
then I will again pass in the argument of zero.
Now before we test this, I want to change
the ordering in here. So first we'd like to
change the configuration of
this background color to red.
And then we'd like to throw a message. Alright,
so now let's go ahead and play the game and
intentionally click on a mind, right, so
let's try to click somewhere here. Okay,
so we can see that we receive a general message
box. Now you can see if we show this side by side,
like the following, then you can see that at
first, what is the message box here with this.
So you can see that the first ring was responsible
to the body of our message box, because we see the
you clicked on a mine in its body. And you can
see that the second text was responsible to show
the title. Now, those numbers here and here are
responsible to deliver your specific kinds of
message boxes. Now, the fact that I have zero here
is responsible to give me only one option of a
button to click, and that will be okay. I think
if I was to change this to something like two,
then I will receive the options of yes, no and
cancel something in that kind. So I'm going to
re run our game. And again, I'm going to lose
it. Okay, so you can see that I was quite right,
it is abort, retry and ignore. And you can try
to play around with different numbers, and you
will see different results. But for myself, I
only want to receive, okay, just confirm it,
and continue with rest of the actions that I want
to do. And I'm going to refer you to a link which
will explain you what number is responsible for
what. So if you want to take further actions with
this message box, be sure to check the link in
the description. Alright, so I'm going to press
somewhere, just turn it back to zero, and maximize
our PI charm and continue from here. Alright,
so right after we have this message box, and right
after we clicked OK, then we should just terminate
the game, we should exit it. Now you have all
the options, what you'd like to do, whenever you
click OK, you can also decide that you'd like to
develop a functionality to restart the game, I'm
just going to exit it. And the way that you exit a
Python process that is running is by Cys dot exit
like that. Now Cys is a library that you should
import. So I'm going to scroll up and say,
import Cys. And let's see if everything together
is going to work perfectly for us. So I'm going
to run the game. And let's try to again lose
it intentionally. Okay, so you clicked on
a mine the second that I press OK, it should be
terminated. And that's exactly what is happening.
So that's a perfect thing. And now we have
a complete game that we can try to play,
we can try to win it. And we might also lose it
sometimes. And we just need to play again until
we win the Minesweeper game. Alright, so now that
we have done this, then there are several things
that we also want to finish out before we have
the complete game without any bugs and without
any problems. So now if we try to play the game,
and let's assume that we have some minds that are
candidates for a mind, so let's just randomly
click here. And then let's assume that I marked
this as a mind candidate, although it doesn't make
sense. And right after that, I left click on that,
right like the following, then you can
see that now we have a bit of problem,
because we might also expect to have the original
background color again. So what we need to do,
we need to also specify in case we left click
on a cell and we open it, we also want to be
configuring the background color to the original
system button face color that we used. So that's
exactly what we should do now, in order to
not face with a situation like the following
where we have an open cell, but we also have
the cell as being shown like mine candidate,
which is pretty funny and we need to handle that.
So, we should go to our open cell method or show
cell here it is and we should be doing the exact
same action of changing the background color to
system rather than face right here. Right so
we can go ahead and say here something like
if this was a mind candidate, then for safety, we
should configure the background color to system
button face something like that. So we can really
understand in the future why we have done this
here as well. And I'm just going to do the same
thing like we have done previously. So it's going
to be self dot cell btw and object dot configure
So that's going to be BG equals to system,
button face, like that. And let's go ahead and
check if this is going to fix the bug for us.
So I'm going to click here, mine candidate, and
then left click. So this looks great. This looks
like it works. So we can continue to do the next
things that we want to do right now. All right,
so now, we might think that we have the perfect
game without any bugs. But let me tell you that we
still have some problems that we could figure out
in order to have the perfect game and the perfect
code for the game. So if we try to launch our
game, then let's try to click on some places here,
like here, in as well as there. Alright, so
Brock is great. But yet, let me tell you that
if we click with our left, click on Sunsail, then
this still is going to call the left click Actions
metal, which that might be something that we want
to avoid, because there is no reason to call any
method, if we already open a cell. And it might
seem like it doesn't do anything to because the
sales left amount is not decreasing. But actually
something is happening in the background. Okay,
let me prove you by also try to
click with my right mouse click.
So if we right click now, then you can see that I
can still mark those as mine candidates, which is
not good. So the way that we want to handle
this is by canceling the events for the buttons,
I mean, the cells that already have been
opened. So the way that we can do this
is use the opposite action of the method that
was responsible to assign the event. So we
assigned some events in the beginning of this
entire series. Now, if a cell has been opened,
we want to cancel those events. So let's go ahead
and see how we can do that one. So we can see
that here, we assign events for left click,
and for right click. So if we open a sale,
then we should do the opposite action. And let
me tell you that TK inter has a method that is
called unbind, meaning cancel all the events that
are assigned to that specific button, right. So
that's exactly what we're going to do just right
now. So I'm going to go to our left click Actions.
And I'm going to execute here some lines that
will be responsible to cancel all the events
on the click till so I'm going to say cancel, left
and right click events, if sale is already opened,
and that is safe to do that, because in case we
left click on a sale, then we open a sale. And
if we lose the game, then the game just exits. So
it makes sense to write here, this functionality.
So it's going to look like self dot cell btn
object.on Bind, and we're going to need to
call this twice. So we are going to unbind the
events for button dash one. So I'm going to just
copy this string and paste this in here. And
I'm going to do the same for button dash three.
And that should be responsible to cancel all
the events. Now let's check if that's going
to work. So I'm going to launch the game and
click somewhere. And now I'm going to try to
right click on that you can see nothing happens.
And that's exactly what we want. Let's also test
with some other locations like here, here and
here, maybe so now I will try to left click,
you can see nothing really happens. If I right
click, and again, nothing really happens. But if
I right click here, then something's supposed
to happen. So that's exactly what we want.
We want to cancel the events for the sales that
are already open. Alright, so there's going to be
one final thing that we want to do before we can
play the game from the beginning to the end. Now
the case that we win again, is in case that we
have the amount of sales being equal to amount of
minds. Let me repeat that. Now let's say that in
this case, we have nine mines in our game, right?
Because if you remember, from settings.py, we know
that mines count is cell count divided by four.
Now in our case, it is six power of two, which is
36 divided by four is nine. So whenever we have
nine sales left in the game, but we still able
to play the game, then here's the exact case
that we can Arrays the message
that we want the game, right?
Congratulations, something in that kind. So that's
exactly the last thing that we want to do just
right now. All right, so let's go ahead and
try to design this, I will go to cell.py file,
and it makes sense to raise a message like
congratulations. If on show sale, we have
the expected match, right, where sales count is
equal to the minds count. So I can just go under
the self dot show sale. And I can say something
like, if minus count is equal to the sales,
left count flayer one, something like that. And
let's write this right. So I'm going to say if
cell dot cell count, if you remember, this
was a class attribute is equal to settings
that mines count, then I'm just going
to copy the line that was responsible to
show a message. And I'm only going to change the
text inside of that. So let's find this message.
It should be in the show mine method. So I'm
going to just Ctrl F that, and you can see that,
here it is. So I'm just going
to copy that and paste this in
right here. And I'm only going to change the
arguments. So I'm going to say, game over.
Congratulations, you won the game, something
like that. Alright, so now that we have this,
let's play our game from the beginning to the
end. All right, so before we go ahead and try
the game from the beginning to end, we said
that we'd like to have a title for the game.
And that's something that we should do earlier. So
let me do that quickly. Let's do this together by
writing a game on the score title is equal to a
label, we said that for creating a pure text, it
is a great idea to use the label class or TK inter
library. And we want to position this in the top
frame, we want the background color being black,
and the foreground color, meaning the text color
to be white. Now we'd also like to pass
in here text equals to mine sweepable.
Minesweeper game, and the font should be a
tupple. And the first argument of the tupple
should be the font type. So you can play
around with any form type you'd like to,
I will just leave it an empty string. And I will
say size is equal to 48. Like that. And now that
I have this, then I'm also going to say game title
dot place. And let's use 25% of the weight size of
the top frame. We have this utils dot weight brct,
which receives the amount of percentage to use
from the x axis. And now that I have this, then
I'm going to go out from this parenthesis and
I'm going to say y is equal to zero. And then
I'm just going to launch the game and you can
see that it looks great. Alright, so speaking
about playing the game, let's try to figure out
how we can win that game. So just going to
play it and guess where the mines are located.
Alright, so we have my one mines around here. And
we clicked on a mine. It might take a few times
until we win it. But let's hope for the best.
Okay, so that's a mine as well. That was a mind
if we click here on the middle, so we have three
here, so it's quite dangerous to try to figure
out where the minds are located. Okay, so we have
some zeros and that's the best practice probably
to go with. Okay, so you can see that around this
one around this one here we have one mind. So say
that we guess that we have a mind here, then we
are allowed to click there. Okay, so we guessed
right. And so you can see that here we have a one.
And there is already a mind here, so we can click
here for sure. Alright, so now we need to
figure out where rest of the minds. So here
we have three minds surrounded and as well as
here. So I'm going to assume that we have a mind
here for sure. And as well as here. So
this means that we don't have a mind
here, and we lost the game. So let's give
it one more try. Maybe you can win it let
me know in the comment section. If you can win
this Minesweeper game it is quite important.
And let's give it a last try and promise I'm
not going to try anymore because the video
is just going to be too long. All right,
so if we click here, so we have one mind
around here, so I'm not going to get that.
Okay, so some zeros zeros are great for us. And
going to get that here we have a mind.
So here, we don't have a mind. All right,
nice guess. So now, it means that I can click
here, here, here, here and there. And also here.
So you can see that now looking at this
one, you can see that there is a mind here,
so I'm also allowed to click there. Also here, and
also here. Alright, so now that we have this, we
can also try to click here because we have a one
there. Okay, so now we know that we have one mind
around this one. So that's a mind for sure. And
this means that if we look in this number, then
we can also click here, here and
here. Alright, so looking at this one,
we can click here, because that's a mind for sure.
So now we can look on this one. That's a mind that
we marked as a mind candidate, so we can click
here. Alright, so now it is getting complicated.
If we get that here, we have a mind. Then
we can left click here. Alright, great guess
we can continue playing. So we can see that
looking at these three, these in that our
minds. Absolutely right. So we already found
six, three more to go. It's quite exciting.
All right, so I think I don't have anything
left to guess. So I need to go here up top.
And I'm going to think that that's a mine. So
if I left click here, oh my god. Alright, so
I will leave you the all the time in the world to
try to figure out and play the game and win it.
And I think that's pretty
much it about this series.
Now, as usual, if you enjoyed this entire course,
please be sure to hit the like button. And that's